it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning waking up under curfew in the
ukrainian capital kiev following a new
warning from the u.s president about
russia's possible intentions with
chemical weapons small business minister
paul scully will be joining us on the
show in just a few moments time i'll
also be speaking to the former head of
the british army lord danette and the
former foreign secretary lord straw plus
amidst calls for the government to act
after piano sacked hundreds of staff
i'll be asking the general secretary of
the tuc what more if anything can be
done it is tuesday the 22nd of march
clamping down russian troops turn on
peaceful protesters in the occupied city
of carson
living in the shadows we report from
kharkiv a city under attack where
underground trains have become makeshift
homes
how long have you been living here uh
three or three every three weeks how do
you feel about it so first where will we
hear something blow up we're around here
but now
what was that oh shooting
a very good morning from odessa in south
ukraine a city which saw its first
shelling from a russian warship as
president biden warns russia against the
use of chemical weapons
he's already used chemical weapons in
the past and we should be careful what
about what's about to come
deadline day bosses at ferry company p
and o have until this afternoon to tell
the government exactly why they sacked
800 staff
no sign of survivors we'll be live with
rescue teams in southern china after a
plane with 132 people on board crashed
into mountains
but just why did it happen
i'm in the mountains of guante in
southern china's rescue workers pick
their way through the devastation at the
crash site
a tragic incident
a toddler has died after being attacked
by a dog her family had only bought a
week ago
a royal tribute prince william's message
to ukrainians struggling for survival
during his tour of the caribbean
today we think of those struggling in
ukraine
and we stand with them in solidarity
also ahead on the programme i'll be
joined by the london restaurateur who's
taken his pizza oven to poland to help
feed refugee
children three years ago in secret i
started digging a tunnel which would go
from my workshop to my house and
eventually onto the bunker in the back
garden and this is where we're at
tunnel vision we'll be speaking to the
inventor who spent two years digging a
tunnel under his garden from his house
to his shed
but why we'll tell you at 20 to 10.
[Music]
morning all ukraine's capital is waking
up under curfew this morning the
breaking news in the last few minutes
from the ministry of defence is that
russian forces around the country had a
day of limited progress with most forces
largely stalled intelligence also
suggests that despite heavy fighting
ukrainian forces continue to hold off
russian attempts to capture mario paul
well these are the latest developments a
curfew remains in place in the capital
kiev until 7am local time tomorrow
president biden has warned that moscow
could be considering using chemical
weapons
for his part president zielinski says
that any potential deal agreed in peace
negotiations to end the war will be
submitted to the ukrainian people in a
referendum
and dozens of ukrainian orphans and
their carers who are due to fly from
poland to the uk on monday
are still stuck in poland because of
missing documentation
pretty shocking pictures these russian
troops reportedly using stun grenades
and firing shots to disperse protesters
in the occupied city of carson
video showed several hundred
pro-ukrainian protesters in the city's
freedom square running as what appeared
to be stun grenades landed around them
loud bangs could be hurt and there are
plenty of clouds of smoke well according
to ukrainian officials at least one
person was wounded
[Music]
meanwhile the chechen leader ramzan
kadarov has posted a video on his
telegram page that he says shows chechen
fighters taking part in russia's
offensive against mario paul scan news
cannot independently verify the date
location or indeed conditions under
which these images were shot
chechnya fought unsuccessfully for
independence from russia its leader is
appointed by moscow
new satellite imagery released by the
private us space technology company maxr
show the scale of the damage that russia
has inflicted on ukraine cities
plumes of smoke can be seen billowing
from parts of the northern city of
cherniv and again in european outside
kiev yesterday damage also visible in
the encircled port city mario paul
president biden has again warned that
moscow is considering using chemical
weapons in its war against ukraine
his back is against the wall and he's
now he's talking about
new false flags he's setting up
including
he's
asserting that we the america biological
as well as chemical weapons in europe
simply not true he's already used
chemical weapons in the past and we
should be careful about about what's
about to come
ukraine says it will not surrender its
cities
and has accused russia of striking
residential areas in its first attack on
odessa let's bring in sky's nick martin
in that strategic black sea port city
nick good to see you as always i mean
two significant developments i would say
at one president biden reiterating those
concerns about the use of chemical or
biological weapons but where you are
shelling coming from the russian navy
yeah it was a significant day yesterday
neil good morning um because it was the
first time that the russian warships
that we've been seeing off the coast
here in odessa for a few weeks now it's
the first time that shells fired from
those warships actually made contact on
the ground
we were talking yesterday morning at
that site which uh which had been struck
by about six
shells so smashing an apartment block
and it certainly uh frightened the the
people there and i think the general
consensus is that this was perhaps the
russian mil the russian navy carrying
out some sort of test fires to see how
close they could come in to the coast
and how far inland they could reach
their shells because those shells have a
range of about 20 to 25 kilometers
depending on the weather conditions and
so it could have been some kind of test
of odessa's defensive systems but it
certainly caused a bit of damage there
has been some shelling before the very
beginning of this conflict in the city
and the shelling yesterday was on the
outskirts of the city just to the south
but for what i can see here this morning
it's not sent people into a panic these
people are very stoic they've been
spending weeks fortifying their city and
there's cars coming and going i can see
people walking their dogs and when we go
into town in a little bit i'm sure some
of the shops are open having said that
there's no complacency they always
expected this port city to be
attacked in some form it is just so
strategically important and yesterday
could have been a warning sign of that
nick many thanks indeed
we're once again joined by the minister
for small business paul scully mr scully
great to have you in and of course lots
to talk about rather closer to your
brief but let's start with that we are
once again seeing in ukraine
president biden has once again issued
concerns about russian potential use of
biological or chemical weapons if those
were to be used that would undoubtedly
be a war crime wouldn't it yeah
undoubtedly and uh i think you know uh
president biden and prime minister have
been really resolute in making sure that
we can do take every action with the
international community to um address
those those crimes of vladimir putin
we've got to remember as well with all
of this is that this is vladimir putin's
war against russia and kremlin's war
against russia against ukraine it's not
the russian people so we've got to make
sure that uh we can appeal to the
russian people uh to to bring an end to
this
those in ukraine will of course be
concerned as to whether or not this is
president biden speculating on the basis
of you know the russians stall in
various parts of the country or perhaps
whether as has happened on a number of
occasions in the past the americans are
revealing intelligence do you know which
of those it might be i don't know is the
honest answer but you know i wouldn't
like to speculate cool
just in terms of of the sanctions there
have been a couple of super yachts that
have been moved around recently italy um
has been urged to to seize the super
yacht allegedly linked to vladimir putin
uh the shahirazad i mean
is that the type of action that we would
wish to see i mean there's the boat i
mean it's pretty big you can't miss it i
mean would you support the italians in
taking that type of well i think what i
can talk about is what we've done we've
uh we've sanctioned more than a thousand
individuals and entities we've been very
much on the front foot in uh passing the
economic crime bill which i did last uh
last week which uh included uh
registering the ownership of um or the
the the um the beneficial ownership of
um properties within the uk so that we
can use that as a tool to better
sanction target sanctions against the
individuals that are supportive of putin
just on just on that point though i mean
how close are we really to knowing who
owns these large empty buildings that we
see scattered around knightsbridge and
so on well i think with that's exactly
what their register is there to do uh
what it will do is uh when people have
bought something through a shell company
they will have to register who actually
owns it who's the beneficial owner of it
now there's 95 000 odd properties that
are involved in that and most of those
clearly are not owned by oligarchs it's
important to remember that many many
people use those for legitimate reasons
but uh it will give us a useful tool for
the um intelligence agencies and
enforcement agencies to be able to
target the right people yeah one day
i'll have a legitimate reason to own a
50 million pound mansion and let's
though let's let's move on to your
briefing and in terms of piano fairies
the accusation has been from
particularly from those who have been
sacked who haven't signed non-disclosure
agreements is that you heard about it
the night before they were told over a
zoom call and did nothing about it i
just want to give you the opportunity to
to counter that allegation no oh it's
it's incorrect i mean i i knew nothing
about it but the secretary of state was
informed the night before that the
company was going was going to be
announcing redundancies the following
day um not as in the debate we heard
yesterday that there were going to be uh
balaclava wearing
security guards or anything like that
and the uh piano ferries
have made redundancies over the last
couple of years each year over the last
couple of years as well because they are
in a not good financial state and so he
expected it to be going along the same
way as those redundancies announced
previously rather than the situation
that we've seen the absolutely egregious
situation that we've seen so it's just
to be absolutely clear despite the
transport secretary told that 800 people
were potentially about to lose their
jobs he didn't feel it was necessary for
either him or any of his junior
ministerial colleagues to pick up the
phone and speak to piano ferries well
what normally happens with redundancies
if we get if you're in a situation where
you say there is going to be an
announcement that normally that's an
announcement of
the consultation the notification that
is required um under the law and bear it
in mind that the notification which is
why i and my boss quasi quartet have
written to the chief exec of piano
fairways to get further detail because
it's important that we get the exact
detail not just um the various um
amounts of media stories that we're
getting we need to collate it in one
place because there are criminal
sanctions uh involved in this so
including an unlimited fine for which
which is all which is all post hoc
unfortunately the complaint that is
being made by the staff is that in those
few hours that window of opportunity
before that zoom call came and before
those sackings were issued there was an
opportunity for the government to speak
to p and o ferries now i understand that
after the fact when you've heard all of
these details you're utterly aghast but
surely before the announcement was made
should have been the opportunity for
this government to put in a check call
it doesn't even have to be a minister a
civil servant could have done it i mean
to be fair just the uh the you know the
hours that we that we had before was
not even enough time to step up our uh
department working pensions uh team let
alone actually try to reverse the
decision but nonetheless we have said to
p no fairies first thing get round the
table reverse the decision speak to the
union speak to the workers but it is
perfectly possible that what piano
ferries have done is entirely legal
they're not flagged in the united
kingdom they sail in international
waters the allegation is that they have
hired in indian agency staff on less
than two pounds an hour and it could
potentially be perfectly legal there is
nothing as of seven o'clock this morning
to stop another company from doing
exactly this if they're operating in
similar circumstances to penalties well
this is the complication it's about
jurisdiction a lot of this is about
jurisdiction as you say it was the
vessel isn't flagged within the uk uh i
understand that contracts may not have
been signed within the uk um either and
that this is all the things that we're
trying to determine nonetheless the
point still stands if it is a business
on land in the uk within your uk
jurisdiction
there are plenty of laws in place which
which carry criminal sanctions are we
going to change the law though to
prevent firing and re-hiring well this
wasn't really a uh case of foreign
by the dft that their ambition was too
far and rehear
at more favorable conditions
that was in the civil servants note but
the the ambition was to re-har other
people uh so there was you know you've
got 800 people sitting now in the uk
without a job that had no opportunity of
going back to the job and that's why
that consultation uh was is so important
but this is this was a case of mass
sackings that were done in the most
callous way okay so what are we going to
do about it so as i said we are
establishing the fact now we we're
expecting it we're expecting an answer
if it proves that they haven't acted
illegally if they haven't acted
illegally under english law maritime law
what are we going to do well if if they
have then what we absolutely reserve the
right to approach prosecuting
authorities to to tackle this if we if
we haven't uh then obviously we want to
make sure that we can support the um the
800 people who have lost their jobs to
make sure that they can uh get back into
into good work um but we'll have to work
with um international partners because
this is as you say a complex uh web of
international maritime law um when you
have vessels flagged with other
other countries i i do want to take you
away from your brief again we'll return
to just at the end and nazanin's gary
radcliffe spoke spoke very movingly
yesterday about her years in
incarceration and indeed her complaint
that successive foreign secretaries
could have sorted this out if as we were
told by liz trust the other day that
this was a debt that this was an
obligation that we had to the iranians
of 400 million pounds there of
thereabouts
if that was a debt that we owed on the
last day of her incarceration it was a
debt that we owed on the first day of
incarceration so i will ask again the
question that she asked why didn't we
play it before now well first of all it
was just such a pleasure to see nazanin
and looking in such good shape as well
i'd seen her after all she's been
through i'd seen richard throughout both
of his hunger strikes and uh you know he
he um he really suffered as did she as
did her family so it's lovely to see her
back but clearly what we had to do uh
the government had to do is to make sure
that um yes it was a debt that that uh
that was there to be paid it was worked
in in parallel but it was a complex
situation to make sure that that debt
worked alongside sanctions uh from a
number of countries around the world
with with iran that was you know it's
not something that was uh relatively
easy to to sort out but huge but you
rewind you rewind to december 2017 when
one boris johnson was foreign secretary
and was trying to secure nazim's release
you know the line from downing street at
that point was there was absolutely no
link between the debt and naznen's
incarceration in fact it was only in may
2019 the sunday times went to court to
get documents published that showed that
this debt was at the heart of it so
again we also learned that here that two
defense secretaries sir michael fallon
and gavin williamson remember him had
also said no to a foreign office request
for the money to be paid out of the
defense budget there were opportunities
over the six years for this money to be
paid and the government chose not to do
so so doesn't necessarily have a point i
think that as i say the debts were the
debt and her release were ran in
parallel but uh but there was just a
coincidence that they but there's a
place in the same day well there's a
complex set of um um approaches with the
international community when you've got
the us with sanctions against iran when
you've got us with sanctions against
iran it's very very difficult to um to
have have those
any closer together
for fear of what what other what
otherwise might happen in a similar
situation given um kidnaps giving
ransoms and stuff in other parts of the
world
again though naznen's line is if this
money had anything to do with my release
six years into my incarceration
why could it not have been done earlier
you can understand her i can understand
her frustration frankie what she's gone
through is horrendous so i can totally
understand her uh her frustration and as
i say having met richard um a few times
i've seen the the the pain
and anguish of the family over that
period as well so all i can do now now
she is back i'm really pleased she's
back and i'm glad that liz trust acted
the way she did and got her out
resolutely that she can put this behind
her somehow and rebuild that uh time
with her family we have 30 seconds left
in the interview so i suspect you're not
going to give me all the details of the
spring statement tomorrow so why don't
you at least tell me what it is going to
be designed to achieve well look we are
we've got a lot of headwinds uh that
everybody is facing businesses and um
and individuals as well and it's so
important that uh the chancellor will be
looking at the public finances in the
round to make sure he can continue to
flex and support people in difficult
times minister great to have you on
thanks for being with us
uh why don't we have a quick look at the
papers um uh most of the times it
focuses on mario paul at saying that
vladimir putin is threatening civilians
to try and break their spirit
now the telegraph has a picture of what
it believes is putin's half a billion
pound super yacht and it's quite super
isn't it uh it says it could be seized
by authorities in italy
as part of sanctions against russia
sorry just fell over the set
while the guardian reveals what it says
are billions of dollars of assets around
the world linked with russians with
alleged ties to president putin
the mail reports that the man on trial
for the murder of the mp so david amos
had allegedly staked out other mps and
even cabinet ministers as possible
targets
now just a little later we will have a
special report from our correspondent
john sparks in kharkiv where civilians
have made underground carriages into
makeshift homes
how do you feel about it so first we
have when we hear something blow up
we're around here but now we're like
what was that oh shooting
here
well after four weeks of almost
unrelenting russian bombing this is the
new normal for ukrainians in kharkiv
many of whom are looking after babies
one mother we spoke to said that the
trauma of living in this war zone will
stay with her forever
it's a tough but important watch so
please do stay tuned for john's full
report
a pro-kremlin tabloid has removed a post
on their website saying that 14 000
russian troops have been killed and 16
000 wounded in the war in ukraine
the publication now claims its site was
hacked
and that the information that was posted
was fake
russia's last casualty report three
weeks ago said that nearly 500 soldiers
had died
well here we have some social media
footage of anti-war protesters
attempting to blockade a yacht belonging
to the sanctioned russian oligarch roman
abramovich from leaving its dock a group
of people with ukrainian flags boarded a
small dinghy to try and prevent the 430
million pound yacht
from departing turkey's aegean sea
resort of bojan turkey has
not sanctioned russia for invading
ukraine
so to come on the programme well as
russia continues its indiscriminate
bombing campaign where is this war
heading next after half past we'll speak
to the former armed forces chief er lord
dammit
i'll also be speaking to the campaigner
brandon cox on calls for the government
to create a new survivor's charter five
years on from the westminster bridge
terror attack
and after eight we'll be hearing from
liver shadow business secretary jonathan
reynolds
now china's aviation authority said it
was traveling from the city of kunming
to guangzhou a journey of over 600 miles
the plane came down in mountains near
the city of wuzow
emergency services at the crash site
have now found some debris in a heavily
forested area but
still no sign of any survivors our asia
correspondent tom cheshire reports from
near the accident side
this is a small village
quite a long way from wujo the nearest
city it shows you how remote this region
is and this is the center a makeshift
center uh for the search and rescue
operation we've seen people streaming in
and out uh towards the crash site but we
arrived here to the sad news there are
no survivors from this plane crash that
has changed the nature of the operation
here what they'll be doing now is going
to that mountain picking through any
debris it looks like tiny pieces of
debris such as the force of the impact
to try and put together what happened
to this china eastern flight because it
is a mystery at the moment this flight
was cruising along yesterday uh in nice
weather conditions nothing to worry
about and it suddenly plummeted from the
sky at an extraordinary rate of speed it
managed to pull up a little bit and then
dive back into the ground that shouldn't
happen to a modern airplane so the
investigation will be looking at why
there will be focus of course on the
manufacturer of the plane boeing
especially given the history of the two
787 max crashes this was a different
sort of plane but nonetheless china
eastern which is a state-owned carrier
one of china's three flagship carriers
really has grounded all its boeing 7878
boeing has said it will cooperate with
the chinese civil aviation
administrative investigation there are
still relatives gathering in the
airports kunming and guangzhou where the
flight took off from and where it was
headed to
seeking answers but they have got one
very very grim answer already the fact
that there are no survivors on this
plane crash 132 souls on board that
flight which crashed into the mountains
just over there
well some newspapers are reporting that
this image of a plane nose diving is the
plane in question in southern china we
however cannot independently verify this
image
the sun here showing the image of the
plane almost vertical in descent
uh some other news now and two people
have died after an attack at a secondary
school in malmo in sweden an 18 year old
student was arrested on suspicion of
murder
it's not yet clear what happened but
police have confirmed there were no
reports of gunfire
a new study has found the number of
prescriptions written for anti-anxiety
medication have risen sharply
researchers from the university of
bristol found that women are almost
twice as likely as men to be diagnosed
with anxiety
prince andrew remember him well he's
planning to attend the duke of
edinburgh's memorial service according
to reports
the duke of york who recently settled
virginia geoffrey's civil sex claim
against him will reportedly attend the
westminster abbey next week honoring his
father
many members of the royal family the
queen included are expected to attend
meanwhile prince william has expressed
his solidarity with people in ukraine he
was speaking on a visit to a military
base in belize during his tour of the
caribbean this report from sky's royal
correspondent rhiannon mills does
contain flash photography
so
basically
the last royal to come to the ruins at
cahill pech was the queen in her
platinum jubilee year her grandson and
granddaughter-in-law were the ones
delivering her warm wishes
long live the queen
william used the moment to recall his
grandmother's words of praise for belize
in 1994 to then condemn the horrors
taking place in ukraine
she said
i am proud to associate myself with your
determination
that social justice and personal freedom
should flourish under the rule of law
it is always dangerous however
to be complacent
and to assume that democratic values
will look after themselves
vigilance in protecting them
is needed
sadly
elsewhere in the world that vigilance is
being tested today in ukraine
belize has joined many others in
condemning the invasion and standing up
for the principles of international law
peace
and security
today we think of those struggling in
ukraine
and we stand with them in solidarity
it was a reminder these tours aren't all
about sightseeing after morning among
the mayan ruins at caracal the couple
standing on the sky palace still the
largest man-made structure in belize was
the picture until they were joined by
some of us
these pictures are priceless for the
people of belize a tour brings immense
global attention and a stage the royal
couple know they can also personally use
to deliver the messages that matters so
much to them
rhiannon mills sky news in belize
now you may remember this uh well
incredible moment in the early days of
the russian invasion
[Music]
seven-year-old amelia captured hearts
when she sang let it go from the movie
frozen in ukrainian of course in her
bomb shelter well you might want to take
a look at her now
[Music]
she performed the national anthem at a
charity concert in poland the little
girl escaped ukraine three weeks ago
with her grandmother and siblings her
mother and father though have stayed
behind in kiev
[Music]
[Applause]
sweet little girl ah now i wonder if you
can tell which of these incredibly
famous works of art is set to fetch
millions at auction well let's have a
quick look at christy's auction house
has announced
that it's going to sell not the mona
lisa not the self-portrait not the
scream but down there bottom right 1964
andy warhol silk screen of marilyn
monroe how much 200 million dollars
which would make it the most expensive
20th century artwork ever to sell at
auction uh well the painting comes to
christie's from a healthcare foundation
for children and all of the proceeds of
the sale are supposed to be going
towards it
good for them
stay right where you are coming up next
we'll discuss the state of the conflict
in ukraine with the former head of the
armed forces general lord richard
[Music]
he's reaching us from the metropolitan
police force
officers investigating the death of
sabita thanwani and clarkenwell have now
charged a man with murder he's been
named as maher maruf
born 22 years old of no fixed address
due to appear in court a little bit
later on today
of course detectives were called to
clarkenwell to arbor house and sebastian
street at about 10 past five in the
morning on saturday 19 year old sabita
had been found suffering from serious
injuries she was however pronounced dead
at the scene police today announcing
that they have now charged a man with
her murder
but let's just remind you as to our top
stories
[Music]
russian troops have turned on peaceful
protesters in the occupied city of
harrison
[Music]
we have a special report from kharkiv a
city under attack where underground
trains have become makeshift homes
[Music]
and bosses at the ferry company p ro
have until this afternoon to tell the
government why they sacked
800 staff
apple a short while ago i asked the
small business minister paul scully why
the government didn't act to stop the
redundancies he told me he knew nothing
about it
the secretary of state was informed the
night before that the company was going
was going to be announcing redundancies
the following day um not as in the
debate we heard yesterday that there
were going to be uh balaclava wearing um
uh security guards or anything like that
and the uh piano fairies
have made redundancies over the last
couple of years each year over the last
couple of years as well because they are
in a not good financial state and so he
expected it to be going along the same
uh way as those redundancies announced
previously rather than the situation
that we've seen the absolute egregious
situation that we've seen
our political correspondent tamar cohen
is back in the studio and of course
piano have
a deadline they're calling it a deadline
but the second let us know by this time
and as to why they've done all this but
you know putting it to the minister the
biggest complaint that has been made is
that they knew and they did nothing
about it and to an extent we didn't
really get any pushback on that no
yesterday the transport secretary grant
shaps conceded that the government had
been told at least 12 hours before these
800 workers were summarily sacked in a
quick zoom call on thursday last week
but what the government says is that the
proper procedure probably wasn't
followed because you're supposed to
liaise with unions you're supposed to
give the government notice through a
different
outlet so that all the procedures may
not have been followed properly and as
paul scully was telling you there
wouldn't have even been enough time in
12 hours to set up a team to speak to
them let alone reverse the decision
entirely but this issue is not going to
go away the chief executive of piano was
told by the business secretary to
respond to 10 different questions about
why this happened where the workers are
why this didn't happen in other
countries where pno have staff like
france and holland we expect peter
hebelthwaite to get back to them by 5 pm
today and we may well hear more from
ministers today but so far we've had a
lot of hang ringing a lot of it's
appalling and egregious and terrible but
what certainly labor what the trade
unions what staff in other similar
companies may be owned by a foreign
company as its parent company want to
know is how is this going to be stopped
from happening again to other workers
tamara thank you
let's return to ukraine where for many
life is certainly getting harder in
kharkiv families are living in
underground rail carriages to avoid the
russian shelling kharkiv is ukraine's
second city and around 25 miles from the
border with russia
our correspondent john sparks has this
report which does contain images of
injured people
the streets of harkiev have been
abandoned by the majority of those who
live here
half a million have fled this city
their prized possessions in a bag
and their cars discarded at the station
those who remain hide in the shadows in
the dark or the deep underground
more than a dozen metro stations have
been turned into shelters
these battered looking train carriages
redeployed as home how long have you
been living here uh three or three three
weeks how do you feel about it so first
yeah when we hear something blow up
we're around here but now we're like
what was that oh shooting
the experience is a trial for a new
mother called natalia
she gave birth to her son two days after
the invasion began
the hospital then sent her here
they now live in the final car on
platform 2 with a cot and clothes
provided by volunteers
natalia says life will never be the same
again
residents who remain will try to endure
but some are no longer able
the city morgue receives 50 to 100
bodies a day caused by the war and by
natural causes
when a russian missile struck this
institute the entire neighborhood was
damaged in the blast
85 year old stella ivanovna
told us she hung on to the door frame in
the hope she'd survive what was it like
when
the bombing happened when the missile
[Music]
sergey is an opera singer turned
volunteer who was shot seven times as he
tried to evacuate local residents
who was shooting
sergey's body should heal in time
and he celebrated with an old italian
song of resistance
[Music]
death and displacement have come to
everybody's doorstep but there are many
here who are determined to hold on
john sparks sky news harkev
well russia's advance on the capital
kiev has stalled in the face of fierce
ukrainian resistance at let's speak now
to the former heads of british armed
forces general richard dannett lord
danic great to have you on the program
uh once again um i wonder what you make
of the evolution in terms of the the
russian tactics in john's report there
we just had further examples of the
fortitude of your average ukrainian but
it's not just the ordinary ukrainian
that's been taking up arms their their
military as well has served
to stall the russian advances pretty
significantly
yes you're right i think john sparks his
film um
just illustrates very graphically the
difficult circumstances in which the
ukrainian people are living kharkiv as
the report said the second largest city
in ukraine um and what's happening there
is quite appalling but um
part of your introduction is right the
certainly the push by the russians that
um big push down from belarus towards
kiev itself has very much stalled and
there are well
well-founded reports that uh
in the north and the west of the city
the russian forces are going on the
defensive they're hunkering down for for
a long fight for kiev and of course
this is just illustrating the fact that
they haven't got strength or perhaps
even the motivation on the will to try
and push into the center of kiev itself
so they are following that medieval
practice of standing off and shelling
but while that goes on both in kiev and
kharkiv which we were seeing
the
eye of the storm at the present moment
is in the south uh around mario pole and
i think it's very important that we keep
a very close eye on what happens to
mario paul uh the ukrainians are
desperately determined to defend that
and prevent that land link being formed
between crimea all the way through mario
paul through the donbass
into russia itself and that's absolutely
critical because if that land link is
established and the ukrainian forces
have to give up finally mario poll it
means the russians will be able to
redeploy quite a number of forces
possibly perhaps to threaten odessa and
bear in mind that the russians have got
a large amphibious force
at sea threatening odessa so we could
see that an attack being made on that
last port that would give ukraine what's
the last port that gives ukraine an
opportunity to get his exports uh out
into the world shipping lane so
what
watching what's happening in the south
is really really important at the
present moment
well
indeed but but just to pick up and what
what you described i think fairly
accurately
is the medieval tactic of standing off
and and persisting and you know
continuous almost continuous uh
artillery shelling you know if the
ukrainians continue to resist in the
manner in which they do
it looks as if there might not be much
of ukraine left in the not too distant
future
well this of course is the absolute
irony um when vladimir putin launched
this outrageous
attack invasion uh it was with the
purpose of
if you like almost putting an arm around
ukraine and drawing ukraine into the
wider family of russian people
well
i think i think many ukrainians are
fancy uh uh many ukrainians other than
those who live in the most eastern part
of the country and those two eastern
republics but most other ukrainians have
got no interest really now of being part
of a greater russia and frankly
what even would russia gain if in
apparently taking control of ukraine
they're just taking over complete bomb
site uh and destroyed cities
and i think here's another question um
given the historical importance of kiev
does even vladimir putin want to smash
up that historic city
surely he must want to leave something
that uh he could then parade on the
world stage but um the way things are
going
the determination of the ukrainians the
way their civilians are enduring
enormous hardship their military and
their volunteers are fighting most
courageously i can see this thing going
on for quite some time
unless of course
a return is made to the negotiating
table and president zielinski said he's
willing to talk but he must see
vladimir putin face to face around the
table so one really hopes and praise
that that happens sooner rather than
later but then of course the big issue
is what will be on the agenda who is
prepared to compromise on what and that
looks very difficult at the present
moment
there appears to me to be an awful lot
of speculation around ways by which the
the tempo of this conflict might change
we heard from uh
president biden just yesterday again
raising the prospect of chemical or
biological weapons being used some
suggesting the temple could change if we
see the belarusians
coming in i do wonder whatever what you
make given your military experience of
the accusations that have come from
zielinski and others of the russians
participating in acts of genocide is is
that a a tag a title a description that
you find particularly useful right now
well we've walked we've talked about war
crimes for the last month now and that
conversation has almost become
commonplace undoubtedly war crimes are
being committed on a daily basis now the
question is and this is where
international lawyers will start to
scratch their heads at what point do
serial war crimes become genocide
genocide is the systematic elimination
of a genus of other people and i think
mario paul looks to me increasingly like
srebrenica in 1995.
i've given evidence against general
maladic and general kirstich
in the hague and they were indicted for
war crimes i've also given evidence for
bosnia against serbia in their genocide
uh trial as well so we are getting quite
close to the accumulation of war crimes
adding up to a deliberate policy of
trying to remove and eradicate a people
i mean this is an appalling prospect but
um i think it's right that we are
starting to look at that and starting to
consider using that language
um lord dan i wonder if we might just
step away from the discussion about
ukraine and focus on something that
comes close to your role as chair of the
national emergencies trust in a few
minutes time i'm going to be uh speaking
to brendan cox um about the the
survivors at the the survivors charter
give us an idea of why a survivor's
charter and your role as chair of the
national emergency trust why that may
well be so significant we understand of
course that acts of terror cause any
amount of mental anguish but you know
it's rather more than that
well
thank you for asking me that question of
course
we've got two organizations in this
country that respond to disasters the
disasters emergency committee which is
doing a fantastic job in raising money
for ukraine and previously for
afghanistan and then at home to respond
to domestic disasters we have the
national emergencies trust which as you
say i chair and two years ago just about
now we launched our appeal british
people raised 100 million pounds which
was distributed around the country to 15
000 charities and community groups and
of course those groups are made up of
people who were struggling in the early
days
of the pandemic and it's important to
get help to people who are struggling
who are survivors so i think brendan cox
is right to come on the program and to
champion a survivor's charter because
and there's a lot of debate about
people who come through awful things are
they survivors or are they victims in a
sense that's a slightly semantic
conversation but what it means at the
end of the day when something awful
happens it's on individuals that the
focus properly comes and it's
individuals who need help and
the long tail of these tragedies is
invariably a mental health tale
so
that's a really important
area where we need to put more resource
more national resources more government
resource and more charity resorts to
help people when something awful has
happened
immediately help is given but then the
implications of that and the memories of
all that my goodness this will be
happening in ukraine for decades to come
that to memory continues and the mental
health the mental health that is
required with people's mental health is
really really important
certainly is um well danny great to have
you on the program once again thanks for
joining us thank you
let's bring you a little bit of breaking
news and it relates uh to the uh well
the kremlin critic alexei
uh poisoned already by the russian state
that didn't kill him so they threw him
in jail
and now are convicting him of further
offenses a court has decided that he is
guilty of fraud on a large scale
russian prosecutors now seek to to move
alexia navalny to a maximum security
penal quality
as i understand it because of this
additional conviction this means that in
the eyes of the russian legal system he
is a recidivist offender which means he
can be put into
one of those prisons with rather grimmer
conditions than the one that he is
already in uh navalny is already serving
a two-year sentence
given to him under some
pretty speculative at two and a half
year sentence i should say uh for parole
violations uh which were related to some
pretty trump top charges uh designed to
thwart his political ambition
now around 46 ukrainian orphans and
their carers on routes to the uk
well where are they currently they've
been left stranded in poland their
journey was organized by a scottish
charity dinipro kids but missing
paperwork from the ukrainian authorities
has left them stuck in warsaw
the children who come from orphanages in
the dinipro region have been waiting for
the past two weeks to fly to the uk
a toddler has died after being attacked
by a dog that her family had owned for
just a week uh let's speak out to our
correspondent ivor bennett um however we
have heard this story so many times but
it never fails to shock just give us the
details as far as we understand them
yeah it's a truly shocking very tragic
story this the details are still
emerging what we know so far is the
toddler was a girl just 17 months old
and as you say the family had owned the
dog for just
one week the incident happened yesterday
afternoon in saint helens at an address
on bidston avenue emergency services
attended the child was taken to hospital
where she died from her injuries we
don't know much about the dog we don't
know what breed it was but the police
have said it was destroyed and they are
now going to do some forensic tests to
establish what kind of breed it was and
whether or not it was a legal breed
under the dangerous dogs act
either many thanks indeed
today marks five years since the
westminster bridge attack in which six
people died and at least 50 more were
injured in a new report the survivors
against terror group is calling on the
government to do more to help survivors
of such attacks uh very pleased to say
the group's co-founder brendan cox joins
us on the programme brendan great to see
you this morning just give us an idea of
what the survivor's charter is and and
what the
necessity for it is
so when we set up survivors against
terror
a few years ago i think our assumption
was that um when
this terrible thing happens when people
are bereaved or seriously injured that
they would be looked after these are
high profile attacks and you would
expect the whole resources of the state
to be mobilized to support them and what
we found in a survey of our 300 members
was in fact that often wasn't happening
that there are too many people who were
left
languishing on waiting lists for mental
health support for example people who
ended up contemplating suicide ended up
committing self-harm because they
weren't getting the basic support that
they required we also heard from people
who
couldn't afford the basics in life who
had lost their loved one who bought in
um who was the main breadwinner and
simply couldn't afford to stay in their
house they or others who couldn't afford
to adapt their houses to take a
wheelchair that they were then in so
those basic things those basic
uh that basic level of support we found
was lacking so what we're calling for
today is for the government to implement
its promise
to consult on a survivor's chart and
that's a fancy
way of saying a set of guarantees legal
guarantees on things like compensation
on things like
access to mental health support so that
when this awful thing happens when this
attack on our state
takes place that those people are
properly looked after and supported
are there any other countries to which
we can look to for for inspiration and
all of this we've had our fair share of
terror attacks in this country so too
have others however yeah so what we did
in order to inform this this charter
back back in 2019
uh the government boris johnson
committed to consult on a survivors
charter and so what we've done over the
last couple of years is to work on an
analysis looking at france looking at
belgium looking at australia new zealand
israel us canada and looking to try to
understand what are they getting right
that we're getting wrong what are we
getting right that they're getting wrong
and what we found out from that was that
there are some countries places like
france places like belgium where they
just have a completely different and
higher level of support and that's
partly because of the individual areas
of support that they offer but it's also
that they have a different attitude they
see terror attacks
not as an unfortunate accident that
happens to an individual like a car
accident which is the way that we tend
to see it in the uk
um but as an attack on the state that
requires a response from the state so in
france for example um the survivors are
often treated as if they are our
veterans people who are unwilling
veterans of a
of a war and that the state has a
particular responsibility so we think
there are real things that we can learn
and that will both have an impact on the
survivors themselves but we'll also send
out a incredibly strong message that in
the face of terrorism we will look after
each other
brendan cox we have to leave it there as
we are just about out of time but really
appreciate it we'll keep your fingers
fingers crossed that the government
listens
stay we are we will have much more from
in and around ukraine coming next
[Music]